hoch geschätzter herr bundespräsident
hohe geistlichkeit vertreterinnen und
vertreter der gesetzgebenden
körperschaften hohe generalität sehr
geehrte damen und herren im besonderen
darf ich aber sie damen und herren
offiziere des jahrgangs freiherr von
waldstätten und die offiziere aus der
miliz recht herzlich begrüßen
als bundesminister für
landesverteidigung und sport möchte ich
ihnen zur heutigen ausmusterung und
übernahme in das österreichische
bundesheer aufrichtig gratulieren
sie haben eine mehrjährige höchst
fordernde ausbildung absolviert dafür
gebührt ihnen anerkennung und dank diese
wertschätzung für das geleistete gilt
für die heute vier angetretenen berufs
und milizen gleichermaßen von vielen
seiten werden nun ansprüche und
erwartungen an sie gestellt das
österreichische bundesheer hat einen
ausgezeichneten ruf wenn es gilt rasch
und kompetent schutz und hilfe zu
leisten
wir stellen das gerade jetzt wieder bei
der laufenden unterstützungsleistung und
dem assistenzeinsatz mit insgesamt rund
2000 soldatinnen und soldaten
eindrucksvoll unter beweis sie als
angehende führungskräfte haben und
werden dazu beitragen diesen ruf zu
erhalten und weiter auszubauen
in erster linie gilt es nun die
erwartungen der österreicherinnen und
österreicher zu erfüllen
die darauf vertrauen dass unser
bundesheer dann funktioniert wenn not
am mann oder an der frau ist sei es bei
naturkatastrophen im rahmen von
sicherheitspolizeilichen assistenz
leistungen oder auch im auslandseinsatz
in diesem sinne darf ich sie auffordern
das leistungsvermögen unserer truppe bei
jeder sich bietenden gelegenheit und
möglichkeit nach außen zu tragen
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
offiziere des jahrgangs freiherr von
waldstätten sie haben einen
beispielgebenden österreichischen
offizier als vorbild ihres jahrgangs
namen gewählt wie ich vormittags bei der
sponsion sfeir schon gesagt habe gehen
auch sie so wie ihr vorbild
mutig und entschlossen an die gestellten
herausforderungen heran und setzen sie
sich für die zukünftigen belange und
interessen des österreichischen
bundesheeres 1
so halten sie das andenken an ihren
gewählten jahrgangs namen lebendig
leutnant de der miliz das erfolgreiche
bewältigung von einsätzen wäre für das
österreichische bundesheer ohne seine
miliz soldatinnen und soldaten nicht
möglich ich darf nur beispielhaft
anführen dass rund 43 prozent der
truppen im auslandseinsatz durch die
miliz gestellt werden
ich danke ihnen für die doppelbelastung
die sie auf sich nehmen indem sie neben
ihrem beruf im zivilleben auch noch eine
wichtige funktion im österreichischen
bundesheer ausüben
wir erleben gerade in diesen tagen
bildern von kindern familien menschen
die nach einer wochen und monate langen
flucht vor krieg und elend in ihren
heimatländern oft nur mit dem nötigen
bepackt in europa angekommen
sind wir sind gefordert im gemeinsamen
zusammenwirken perspektiven für diese
menschen zu finden
perspektiven für menschen die sich nach
einem stabilen und sicheren umfeld
sehnen wie viele andere in unserem land
leistet auch das österreichische
bundesheer seinen beitrag um diese
flüchtlingskrise zu bewältigen
wir stellen bereits seit monaten
militärische liegenschaften zur
verfügung damit die flüchtenden
menschenwürdige unterkünfte vorfinden
seit mehr als einem monat unserer
generalstabschef hat es schon
angesprochene unterstützen wir mit rund
500 soldatinnen und soldaten durch
pionierleistungen verpflegung 'nen
unterbringungen und transporten vor rund
einer woche hat das österreichische
bundesheer das gesamte transport
management übernommen
ich bewerte das als positiv dürfte doch
diese entscheidung deswegen gefällt
worden seien weil man uns das zutraut
konkret bedeutet das dass wir
federführend sämtliche transporte von
flüchtlingen mit der bahn und auf der
straße mit allen zur verfügung stehenden
fahrzeugen koordinieren
vor allem aber stehen wir mittlerweile
mit rund 1400 soldatinnen und soldaten
im sicherheitspolizeilichen
assistenzeinsatz um in enger
zusammenarbeit mit der polizei
kontrollaufgaben absicherungs und
ordnungs tätigkeiten um ihn und für
unsere republik durchzuführen
ein weiterer aufwuchs unserer kräfte auf
die gemäß ministerratsbeschluss
festgelegt festgelegte höchstmenge von
2.200 soldatinnen und soldaten ist
jederzeit möglich
damit leistet das bundesheer humanitäre
hilfe und stellt einen kontrollierten
und geordneten ablauf der
flüchtlingsbewegungen in österreich
sicher wir werden gemeinsam mit allen
partnern diese herausforderungen
meistern und unseren humanitären auftrag
in gewohnt professioneller weise
erfüllen
das gilt selbstverständlich auch für sie
werte damen und herren leutnant der die
sie davon dass sie davon ausgehen können
schon in kürze mit diesem einsatz
konfrontiert zu werden um krisen dort
entgegen zu wirken wo sie entstehen und
damit zu trägen beizutragen dass gar
nicht erst menschen zu flüchtlingen
werden halten wir auch weiterhin unser
auslands engagement auf hohem niveau
rund 1000 soldatinnen und soldaten des
österreichischen bundesheeres stehen
derzeit bei internationalen
friedensmissionen wie im kosovo in
bosnien im libanon und in der
krisengeschüttelten ukraine und an
anderen krisenherden dieser welt im
einsatz
eine beeindruckende zahl
sie leisten einen wichtigen beitrag zur
sicherheit europas und damit zum schutz
österreichs darüber hinaus werden wir
schrittweise unser engagement in den
krisenregionen in afrika anheben
ich kann ihnen an dieser stelle
mitteilen dass wir nicht nur unser
kontingent im rahmen der eu
trainingsmission in mali auf bis zu 20
personen aufstocken
wir werden nunmehr auch mit bis zu 15
soldatinnen und soldaten an der un
mission minustah teilnehmen
damit leisten wir einen
bedarfsorientierten mit der oder eng
abgestimmten beitrag zur stabilisierung
einer region die potenzieller ursprung
und durchzugs gebiet von
flüchtlingsströmen ist das
österreichische bundesheer wird
weiterhin seine aufträge
im inland in gewohnt professioneller und
verlässlicher weise zur zufriedenheit
aller erfüllen
der schutz kritischer infrastruktur gilt
den vitalen lebensadern unserer heimat
wie zum beispiel unserem stromnetz der
wasserversorgung oder unseren
verkehrsknotenpunkten wie flughäfen oder
bahnhöfen
dieser einsatz ist äußerst kräfte
intensiv daher erhöhen wir die anzahl
der infanterie bataillon und treiben den
zulauf von modernem gerät voran
zur verbesserung in unserer
infrastruktur werden wir alleine heuer
75 millionen euro einsetzen
weitere rund 100 millionen euro flossen
und fließen 20 15 in neues gerät darüber
hinaus habe ich entschieden
zusätzliche 79 millionen euro noch heuer
schwergewichts mäßig in den schutz und
die mobilität unserer soldatinnen und
soldaten zu investieren
parallel dazu ist es gelungen ein von
generalstabschef schon angesprochene
sonder investitionspaket von 616
millionen euro auf die beine zu stellen
dadurch wird das budget des
österreichischen bundesheeres erstmals
seit jahren wieder steigen und ab 20 16
über zwei milliarden euro liegen
auch die miliz deren primäre auftrag
nunmehr der schutz der kritischen
infrastruktur ist wird aufgewertet und
österreichweit bis 20 18
um weitere zwölf kompanien ausgebaut
einer meiner wesentlichen schwerpunkte
ist die reform des grundwehrdienstes wir
schaffen wahlmöglichkeiten
wir haben die mitbestimmung für unsere
rekruten erhöht wir investieren in
intensivieren die sport ausbildung und
vieles mehr
um einen sinnvollen abwechslungsreichen
und lohnenden wehrdienst zu ermöglichen
ist investieren wir jährlich zusätzlich
30 millionen euro aus unserem budget
ich will dass der grundwehrdienst eine
win win situation darstellt zum einen
für das bundesheer und zum anderen für
unsere jungen männer und frauen die
ihren dienst am staat leisten
ich möchte hierbei die gelegenheit
nutzen und allen ausbildern des
österreichischen bundesheeres offizieren
unter offizieren und taschen zur
professionellen arbeit im rahmen der
ausbildung unserer jungen rekruten
gratulieren und ihnen meinen
persönlichen dank aussprechen
als sichtbare anerkennung habe ich
angeordnet dass ausbilder prämien in der
höhe von 17 millionen euro ausbezahlt
werden
meine damen und herren leuten an de
sie werden heute in ein funktionierendes
aber auch bewegtes österreichisches
bundesheer übernommen
seien sie sicherer position bewusst
nicht nur ihm her
auch innerhalb unserer gesellschaft
agieren sie umsichtig und konsequent
zeigen sie hätte wenn es erforderlich
ist
handeln sie aber auch mit der
entsprechenden demut und stellen sie
ihre kameradinnen und kameraden sowie
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter stets
in den mittelpunkt ihrer dienstlichen
entscheidungen das rüstzeug dafür haben
sie bekommen
lassen sie mich aber auch die
gelegenheit nützen den zahlreichen
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter der
theresianischen militärakademie meinen
dank auszusprechen
sie alle stehen hinter der qualitativ
hochwertigen ausbildung unserer jungen
offiziere
sie alle tragen täglich dazu bei dass
die wiener neustädter akademie weltweit
anerkennung genießt und keinen vergleich
zu anderen ähnlichen
hochschuleinrichtungen zu scheuen
braucht
lassen sie mich zum abschluss noch einen
mehr besonders wichtigen punkt
ansprechen hoch geschätzter herr
bundespräsident seine verbundenheit zum
österreichischen bundesheer hast du
während deiner gesamten amtsperioden
vielfach gezeigt dein interesse für die
anliegen unserer soldatinnen und
soldaten kam besonders durch die
vielzahl von truppenbesuchen im in und
ausland zum ausdruck auch die
offiziersausbildung war und ist dir ein
anliegen die hochgeschätzte anwesenheit
während seiner gesamten amtszeit bei
allen übernahmen unserer offiziere in
das österreichische bundesheer
dokumentiert das deutlich es freut mich
daher besonders dass dir als symbol für
den ausdruck der wertschätzung heute der
akademie ring in gold verliehen wurde
herr bundespräsident herzlichen
glückwunsch und danke für dein ständiges
wirken zum wohle unseres bundesheeres
meine damen und herren des ausmusterung
des jahrganges 2015
ich wünsche ihnen viel freude an ihrem
beruf
ausdauer sowie erfolg und das
erforderliche soldatenglück es lebe das
österreichische bundesheer es lebe die
republik österreich